foreign
if you're thinking about some you know
one of the biggest Sovereign wealth
funds in the world would you rather have
them as a partner or an enemy
um at the end of the day money talks and
you'd rather have them as a partner
Sports in Saudi will benefit from these
collaborations and these ownership
football F1 boxing golf it's just some
of the sports that Saudi Arabia has
heavily invested in it's threatening to
change sport as we know it so why does
it matter
[Music]
Saudi Arabia has been accused of sports
watching by investing huge sums of money
in global sports brands and formats
Amnesty International described the term
sportswashing as the use of sports by
estate to deflect from its human rights
record this is the form of state level
PR which uses a glamor of Elite Sport to
change the image of a country but Saudi
Arabia isn't the only country accused of
sports watching Qatar has also been
accused of sports watching for the human
rights record over migrant workers
whilst hosting the 2022 World Cup
[Music]
Saudi Arabia's engagement with sport is
one of the hottest topics of discussion
whether it be the formation of the Saudi
Arabian Grand Prix Anthony Joshua's
fight with Andy Ruiz Jr or Cristiano
Ronaldo's 200 million dollar package to
play for our NASA in the Saudi pro
league
foreign
but probably the most high profile
Sports investment from Saudi Arabia was
the purchase of Newcastle United
Football Club
led by Saudi Arabia's public investment
fund bought the club from businessman
Mike Ashley for more than 300 million
pounds in 2021 the public investment
fund is chaired by Saudi Arabia's prime
minister and Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman however earlier this month the
World of Golf announced a shock decision
that nobody saw coming after years of
legal disputes they established PJ tour
and the saudi-backed rebel series live
golf announced they were merging to
create a larger golf Enterprise with
billions of dollars invested into the
sport I still here live like I hate live
like I I
hope it goes away whether you like it or
not
the pif we're going to keep spending
money in golf if you're thinking about
some you know one of the biggest
Sovereign wealth funds in the world
would you rather have them as a partner
or an enemy
um at the end of the day money talks and
you'd rather have them as a partner as
the football summer transfer window
opens and many players opt for moves
pundits like Jamie carragher have
expressed concern about the growing
Saudi influence in sport he tweeted I
wasn't worried about the Saudi League
taking place in their 30s a touchworldly
players below the elite but if it
happens it feels like a game changer
speaking in February former Manchester
United player and Sky Sports pundit Gary
Neville said the horses already bolted
when it comes to State involvement in
the Premier League we can talk about
State ownership at Manchester United we
have already got two state-funded clubs
in obviously Newcastle and Manchester
City and they've been allowed to come in
already so I find it difficult to be
able to say that Manchester United
shouldn't have then on that other hand
be able to have a qataria ownership
because we've already feel like the
horses bolted on that in that respect
when Abu Dhabi came into Manchester 15
years ago and obviously Saudi Arabia
came into Newcastle only two years ago
[Music]
human rights groups have ranked Saudi
Arabia as having one of the worst
records in the world it uses beheading
as a form of capital punishment
criminalizes homosexuality and women in
the country face serious discrimination
in 2018 the world was horrified by the
murder of journalist Jamal khashoggi
killed by Saudi agers at the Kingdom's
consulate in Istanbul according to U.S
intelligence findings Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman approved the killing
of Mr khashoggi but he continues to deny
any involvement
speaking at the Qatar World Cup Saudi
Arabia Sports Minister was asked by Sky
News whether the murder of khashoggi
damaged the country's reputation
everyone was horrified by the by what
happened and and everyone condemned it
in the in the Kingdom we've seen a lot
of reforms have happened in the South
and Saudi and you know to make sure that
we the such a thing never happens again
the Washington Post columnist remains
have never been found leading to
questions about the suitability of Saudi
Arabia paying a leading role in sport
[Music]
in 2016 Saudi Arabia launched this
Vision 2030 plan a strategy to diversify
its economy away from oil to become a
world leading Nation for future
Generations Saudi Investment in sport
seems set to stay what remains to be
seen is what sports the country invests
in next